each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay let's uh start i' uh it's
my pleasure to introduce Julia hawm
she's an assistant professor at
uiu uh she is known for her work in
computational linguistic Linguistics and
as well as NLP I look at Julia really as
one of the Pioneers in the language and
vision space she had the courage to go
into the space before object detection
and recognition actually started working
with deep learning so uh it takes a lot
of courage to do that and um she also
popularized one of the one of the more
interesting methods for doing image
captioning which is posing it as a
ranking task so I'm really curious what
Julie is going to be talking about today
uh unfortunately she wasn't able to join
us live but she is going to be joining
us for via Skype so take it away Julia
hi hi everybody um yeah um it's a real
pleasure to be able to talk to you and
fortunately I can't actually see you at
all so this is going to be probably a
little bit weird I can hear you well so
I don't know whether I can hear the
audience if somebody wants to say
something from the
audience
okay I can hear that great thanks so if
you have any questions you can try to
interrupt me okay it's um yeah um so I'm
delighted to be able to speak to you um
I wanted to sort of take stock a little
bit about you know so so there's been a
lot of work on image description over
the last year
especially um that's received a lot of
publicity right as we all know and I
just sort of take a step back and think
about sort of where are we at what um
have we actually solved this task what
are the next steps and so on so um so so
just to to remind
everybody um Right image description uh
means being able to associate images
with complete sentences in English that
describe what's going on in the image
right so um and of course there's sort
of you know there there's more or less
detailed descriptions that are
appropriate for an image some
descriptions like the second one here on
the slide might be a little bit wrong
right you might think this is rugby um
when it's American football but it's
it's probably still sort of an arish
description it's clearly not a dog is
running on the beach though right right
so so and really this variety of
possible descriptions that are all
correct um is what makes this task
really really challenging in a way right
um it makes it challenging to develop
systems for it makes it challenging to
also evaluate in particular because
there is not one gold truth right this
is not like
classification uh um this is this is
much much harder right so so of course
the big question is how would you get a
computer to to describe images right so
so when we started this um more than
five years ago we first thought about
essentially thinking about an a symbolic
sematic representation or
an explicit semantic representation and
and we were doing this on a very very
very small data set the Pascal data set
which I'll talk about in a minute so we
could get away with a really really toy
semantic space right so we thought about
okay images they have um an entity they
have a scene um and they have some
action and and it's only a small number
of these um and therefore we can build a
very very simple model and we can we can
just just learn this mapping to this
very explicit uh meaning representation
space um directly right and that worked
sort of reasonably well there's a lot of
there been a lot of follow and work on
this um with much more you know
realistic um and complex sematic
representations um so that's one way of
going about this and um and I'll get
back to this uh probably s towards the
end of the talk
um but then we also realize that so so
one problem with this explicit sevening
representation is that at least the way
we formalize it at the time it was sort
of very limiting in a way right you you
really had to predefine the space
you had very few predicates right it was
a very very sort of yeah small world
right
um
and um instead of doing that we we
thought perhaps you can do something
else so so so uh um we looked at
techniques that are able to to map two
different kinds of um of spaces to a
common Vector space right which is often
called sort of a shared semantic space
so here's you know so so pictorially the
idea is that you you induce the mapping
from images to to this Vector space and
you also uh concurrently induce the
mapping from captions to the semantic
space and then because they both live in
the same space you can measure the
distances from images to captions or
vice
versa just just by a standard coine
distance for example right
um right so the so the Technique we used
um was was kernel canonical correlation
analysis or
kcca um right wait and then so so this
induces this mapping um and then at test
time right you map both unseen images
and caps into the space and then you can
rank sentences for example by the
distance to the query image or vice
versa right so you have the same model
for image description as well as for
image
search right so of
course um even if you know how to learn
this mathematically you still need to be
able to learn this from some data right
so so we need to get data sets to
actually to actually develop this task
so of course images are really easy to
get right um there's billions of them on
the web but that's not a problem the
problem is of course where do we get the
captions from well you might say okay if
you go to like flicker for
example which is the website we've
mostly been been using um there's a lot
of text on um on the side right It's
associated with the
images um so there's tags and there's
also um descriptions right but
unfortunately um none of these
descriptions really say what we would
like the computer to say for this image
right none of these captions say there's
there's a man um pading a stingray right
which is sort of the you know one of the
the very many plausible descriptions
right the fact that this was a Discovery
Cove in Orlando is really kind of
immaterial right this provides
additional context but doesn't actually
describe the image in a way that we want
the computer to be able to
do right so these so these descriptions
are really not appropriate for the task
we're interested in right but so so why
is this well so so the reason why people
don't actually describe their own images
has to do sort of with a a very basic
principle of communication right they
called the graan maxims namely you want
to be informative right or you don't
want to bore your um um the people
you're talking to or the people you're
writing for in this case right right so
of course other people can see what's
going on in image they don't need the
description right that we want the
computer to
produce therefore what we have to do is
actually collect our own
captions right um and we use
crowdsourcing um because we wanted to do
this at a fairly large scale um and that
seemed to work surprisingly well and
with enough quality controls in place
you can it turns out you can actually do
this so so we started out um with just a
thousand images from the Pascal 2008
challenge so so I think this was like 20
different object categories um and and
50 images per per category and then we
collected five captions per image um so
just to give you some examples um of how
this data looks like right so so so for
example here we have a picture of a
plane right um or a picture of a bird
um right
so
um in a way this data I mean so so a lot
of people have used this data set um
even though it's really quite small with
only a thousand
images um but I'm really an NLP person
and I was really more interested in like
descriptions of events and so on so and
I felt that this data set wasn't all
that interesting we really wanted to
have
more um images of people doing things
right or possibly animals right so then
we started actually going to Flickr and
collecting images there uh we started
out with with Flickr 8K right so that's
about 8,000 flicker images again five
captions per image crowdsourced
um which we've since extended to to
what's now of called flicker 30k which
is about 32,000 images um again with
five captions for image and there we
really really try to
capture um very wide variety of what
people do right different so um um
actually the images you see here in the
background are all taken from this data
set um the other advantage of flicker
30k is also that
essentially all of the images are um
have are creative commment license right
so we can actually distribute the images
easily right so that's um uh that made
it a bit more difficult to um to select
these images but we think in the long
term it makes it much um easier to
maintain the data set right so again
here are some
examples from this data set right so so
here so here's an image of like a hockey
game right um or um um right about of
teenagers getting drinks right uh at a
store right and you can really see the
um the convenience the um the variety of
captions right the the variety of
different descriptions that that can be
associated with the same image right and
that's again that's what makes this task
so interesting and so challenging at the
same time right so how do you measure
how well the system describes images
right well so so as Larry said we really
framed this as a ranking problem
so so we so for example for image
description right you have you have a
pool of
images um oops
um um
sorry um you have a pool of unseen
images and captions and you want to rank
the captions for each
image right the same for image search
right now you can take the these unseen
Capt and you can rank the images um for
um for each caption right and then how
do you evaluate this well so so the test
will say contains a thousand images and
their captions therefore it contains the
original caption of the test images um
this allows us to to then measure the
rank of the original caption in this
list of a thousand items and then we can
report the recall at one or five or 10
so how often is the original item the
first returned result or among the top
five or among the top
10 right why do we use ranking well we
we actually found that this really
allows for for pretty objective and
directly comparable evaluation that
correlates really well with human
judgments um and unlike say Generation
all systems have access to the same pool
of sentences it makes it it much easier
to compare different systems
directly right here just just a few
results from our old paper right so um
so so these are the first ranked
captions for each of these images again
these are unseen but but quite often the
system makes mistakes
also this is my favorite that the
basketball play is in
action um how so so numerically how well
does this work so we were really
surprised we were really surprised that
out of a thousand images you know uh 30%
we would get you know uh the the
original item um among the top 10 10
right that was um at the time that was
that was you know we didn't expect this
to work so well at all right these are
really old results there no no detectors
whatsoever there's there's no new Nets
at all we just use pyramid kernels over
a very low-level visual features to sift
and texture and
color right nowadays right of course we
use deep learning and and the results
have really really jumped but these are
now results on flicker 30k but again the
same kind of 1,000 image test set right
so now uh we're getting really much much
better
results um
so um but all of these methods are
really very very shallow right couldn't
we do better right couldn't we actually
use like object recognition Etc right
the problem is of course that the that
these data sets
are are generally completely disjointed
from from image description data sets
right but perhaps with the exception of
Ms ccoo of course course so so we really
thought well we need data with much
richer annotations that really links the
captions directly to the images right so
so just recently we've released a new
version of our data set which we call
flicker 30k
entities um which augments the original
data set with bounding boxes and core
reference chains for all mentioned
entities right again this was this was
done by
crowdsourcing right so I just want to
give you a few examples right so here
here's a particularly simple example but
so the bounding boxes have the same
color as the dimensions right so for
example here's one one really really
simple cor of chain but but everybody
mentions the
man um only two people mention the
earring right um only four people
mention the glasses and so on right
everybody mentions this hat because it's
really
weird right but so now we actually have
exposit annotations right but sometimes
the annotations are are um much more
interesting for example here right so
the group of people right and the flags
they each refer to a set of entities
right so we we Tred to bounding boxes
for each of them
right um plural mentions are
particularly interesting because because
these These Chains may also intersect
right so so so there are pictures where
like say there's a couple and somebody
mentions a man and a woman somebody else
mentions the couple and so on right so
there's actually lots of really really
interesting problems in this data
so do these entities help turns out that
yes so so uh here at the bottom you see
our results now on the same task we be
use the same kind of CCA technique uh as
before now now of course with um with NE
net based Vision features uh where we
just added the region phrase pairs as
additional training data so again
there's no explicit um detection going
on at test time we just trained the
model more data and that really really
helps helps right right even though that
additional data is just essentially
drawn from the same training data as
before
right
so so does this mean that we've actually
solved imish description right I mean
like we're we're really doing
surprisingly well right it's you look at
the results they're they're pretty good
right are we done well I really think
that learning to associate images with
with these simple sentences that
describe them is a much much easier task
than I think any of us would have
thought a few years ago right this is
really really surprising right and I
think a lot of this really good you know
has to do with with how well Vision
Works nowadays right these these these
deep learning based features are just
just really really they work really well
right they're really
helpful but I think it's important to to
remember that we're really fooling
ourselves right if we think that there's
means that these systems understand
images or simple
sentences right right so could do even
better right but what about ritual
linguistic representations right as I
said I'm really an NLP person I would
like to have a task that shows that you
need viatic representations and so on
but but so far I think the jury is still
out right I mean ex so far so yes we're
using lexical similarities we're using
we're using sort of vector based
representations of words right um but
these are still pretty shallow
representations right so but
linguistically speaking right um
unfortunately uh I think the jury is
still out and I think this has to do
with the nature of this task right but
it turns out that there's just not that
many kinds of sentences for example in
your test pool about a particular kind
of scene right it's that task isn't
really appropriate to really tease apart
these these sort of fine grain semantic
distinctions right right I think it's
very very similar when you look at
generation but the kinds of sentences
that are produced tend to be sort of
fairly simple right wa I think we we
need sort of um now that we've made so
much progress right we need we need sort
of more challenging
tasks right um I'm not sure what what
such a task would look like here um I've
got one one idea of something we could
do now that we have something like f 30k
entities right so for example here's
here's um a sentence um and an image
right and here are the entities right so
we have a woman a child a swing and
another child right and we would like
the system to automatically identify
these entities with their bounding boxes
right
so so so can the system do that
automatically well here here are the
bounding boxes that it
predicts but then when you look at what
which boxes it Associates with uh which
Mansion where things you know so so kind
of works for the woman right um I mean
yeah at least it identifies the head um
but then when you look at the two
children things go wrong right so so she
pushes a child right unfortunately we
think it's the other child right is
while another child looks on right so it
just it just gets these two children
wrong right um well well the swing it
sort of gets right but it's but the two
children might be sort of the the
difficult part
um but is completely wrong and that's
really because the system doesn't
actually understand the sentence right
so I think I think in order to solve a
task like this we need to be able to
really understand both the image right
what does it mean uh to be the child
that's being pushed right what does it
mean to be the child that looks on how
does it look like right um right um
that's a much much harder task than just
saying the symptoms which talks about a
woman and two children in the swing I
describes this image
right right so so I think tasks like
this text to image core reference
resolution may require actual language
and image understanding but that aren't
really being tested by the current task
right so so I don't really know what's
next
right I think we need more challenging
tasks and better evaluation metrics it
actually tests the system's ability to
understand images and language right we
also need need much bigger and more
diverse data sets with with much F
annotations and of course so Ms Coco it
is a really really great example right
but we now have something much much
bigger than flicker 30k right with with
similar kinds of of CFT Source
annotations right that's really
fantastic um uh and we also have abduct
annotations although they're not um
directly linked to the enti to to the
captions right so so really really think
that um that the more of this kind of
data we get the more progress we can
make so I think it's a good start I
think we're um so I'm pretty hopeful
that there's going to be a lot more
really really interesting um things to
happen um uh in the near future so with
this I'd like to conclude and like to
thank my students and my collaborators
uh and my
funders um and here are some of our our
references so thank
you
thank you Julia uh are there any
questions if you use one of the mics
you'll be able to hear
you
anyone no uh Julie on on the co-
references so the
uh
so when when you when you did the co-
references how uh how how much of inner
agreement was there in the mechanical
Checkers were the turkers the humans
themselves agreeing on what was being
referred
to oh that's a great
question I don't have the numbers off of
hand
unfortunately
um so we did L quality
control but I would have to look up the
the actual inter um annotator agreement
um
numbers right I think it's it's
difficult for like plural manions for
example right so it's easy when it's
just a picture of a man right that's
that's
easy um but um it gets really tricky
when there say like like a whole group
of people and somebody mentions some
subset and somebody else mentions
another subset of the
people right so this happens
particularly often in sports right
somebody mentions I don't know two teams
somebody mentions two players from the
two different teams somebody mentions
one player and another player or and so
on right so there's a lot of so uh you
know so these chains intersect right
there's a lot you know and um the
different mentions um in the different
captions and sometimes it's not really
clear right
so um but unfortunately I don't have the
uh the um annotator agreement um yeah
okay yeah
thanks testing testing you hear this yes
uh thank you for a very nice talk and an
area I'm not familiar with and I
appreciate the introduction so I have
kind of a kind of Elementary question I
may have missed something so the um
captions that you're uh evaluating are
all captions that were already entered
by the crowd sourcing is that correct
right yes so what's the status of um
just generating a caption um from for a
new image uh from
scratch um I believe that mag Mitchell
would be a much much better person to to
tell you about that I think she's one of
the next speakers so just stick around
the next two speakers will yes cover
that pretty well I believe yeah right
any other questions all right great
let's uh thank Julia again thank you
thanks all right so our next speaker is
going to be Meg Mitchell she is a
researcher at MSR in the NLP group uh
previously she did a post do at John
Hopkins John's Hopkins
there are s you know how many times M
corrects me I You Can Tell She's NLP and
on Vision I'm just like w whatever um
she's I also look at Meg as one of the
Pioneers in this language and vision
space she did it before it was cool uh
she did some really great referencing
what was it the how did refer to
Everyday visible objects you know it was
really I think well Bey well ahead of uh
what the community was currently doing
when she was doing it so I'm really
looking forward to the talk she that
she's going to give today no
pressure um hi uh so before I begin um
it seems that probably all three talks
are going to be looking at captioning so
I just sort of wanted to quickly say
that this is a vision to language
session and echoing Julia's sentiment
there's a lot of parts to that I think a
lot of us who work on
captioning don't see captioning as the
super cool thing um it's actually a
stepping stone to get further and
further into artificial intelligence so
I want to make that clear as you hear
more and more about captioning work you
know in a year this is going to be old
news we'll probably be able to um get it
well we're close to Human Performance
now let's say um and so so you know take
this talk as a kind of a historical note
um but really why we're looking at the
space is cuz we're interested in looking
at that connection between vision and
language and doing Simple denotative
description is a first pass to see what
what we can actually get at um and
really I think a lot of us are pushing
towards much further richer more
interesting tasks um in the future okay
um so this talk is on the um Microsoft
uh research image captioning system um
this came uh on the heels of the Coco
data set uh that Larry was uh working on
we had a bunch of interns who worked
with us last summer who really made this
come to life um how Fang who's at the
University of Washington um sarab Gupta
who's at Berkeley Forest
deela who's at I don't remember off hand
and rupes is in Sweden
somewhere um I worked most closely with
how and sarab um how worked on the
general generation and sarab worked on
the image analysis um as well as a bunch
of researchers who have been involved
with this as well um and Jacob Devin has
recently entered as kind of a a
newcomer right so uh Janette talked
about this in her talk but one of the
sort of leld dreams of artificial
intelligence is to be able to have uh
computers understand things and one way
to look at this is in terms of image
understanding um this is particularly
interesting to NLP people because this
is a form of grounded semantics we can
associate a word to visual properties
and then we can mine those visual
properties in order to understand the
context more deeply and what our
expectations are about the word not just
in terms of text-based statistics but in
terms what of what we see in the world
um and Julia has this nice work uh she's
cited in uh J the junior of artificial
intelligence research
2013 um where she breaks this down into
perceptual conceptual and non visual
descriptions and the work of image
captioning is largely concrete
conceptual descriptions so these are
specific descriptions which may identify
people and locations their names basic
basic description about what is in the
image and that's what we're focusing on
here um perceptual and non-visual
descriptions and then abstract
conceptual is still to be
done okay um all right
so um I'm going to talk a bit about
previous attempts as uh as Larry
mentioned um you know I started I
started actually working on this as a
linguist in 2005 where I was just kind
of you know I had a pixel and what do I
do with it you know it was it was very
naive at the time um but eventually uh
we got to a point uh around 2011 with
the sort of current Vision techniques
then um where we could start saying
things that kind of sounded humanlike um
we still had to use a lot of hand
engineering and one of the major
problems was that visual detection just
wasn't that good so it was the job of
the NLP to make up for those sort of
Errors um so there were two systems that
uh came out like right before the uh
deep learning revolution in computer
vision um the baby talk system um which
uh was spearheaded by um Alex and Tamara
Berg um and the mij system uh which I
spearheaded working with the Bergs um
and the top one uh in Black here is is
where we are now
uh right so back in 2010 we could say
something like here we see three
bicycles and one road the first grade
bicycle is by the road and near the bubl
and it kind of is sort of long but we're
starting to list all the things we see
and now we're getting to a point where
we can say a group of people writing
bikes down a city street so um we've
come we've come a long way very quickly
and I expect that we will continue uh to
advance very quickly right um so uh
Janette may have stolen my slide um you
guys already know uh who wrote the uh
who which one is the robot and which one
is the um human so I can skip over that
um but the basic approach we took was
this field is exploding right now and
there are so many little parts that we
can look at there are so many aspects to
um how the vision information can be
transformed into language right so when
you're working with vision you have this
continuous representation and you're
working at the Raw pixel level when
you're speaking in language you're
producing sort of discrete categories so
there's some sort of bridge that has to
be um cross to get between these sort of
continuous low-level representations and
what we say uh in a sentence um so we
broke it down into image analysis
language generation and reranking with
the idea that each of these aspects uh
are things that could have pretty nice
algorithms to explore and we could
really dig into the problem um although
it's a bit of a bad word in NLP um we
decided to do a pipeline system instead
of training end to end and this was
specifically because we really wanted to
dig into each of the little parts of the
problems um we also have a trained end
to-end one that's at ACL it doesn't do
as well okay so uh the first step in
this is image analysis um and the idea
behind this was that the words that
should be detected should not be up to
some categories written down by someone
but can be figured out just by looking
at the vocabulary and connecting that to
the image so what we do is we take um
all of the captions uh Associated to
each of the images and each of those
words in the captions uh are then
possibly some sort of visual concept
that we might be able to pick up
um um right and we ended up just
focusing on uh the top thousand most
common words uh which ended up covering
covering 92% of the data um with the
idea being that we can look at an image
and then maybe we can just get a sense
of a ton of different sort of phrases
and words that we can say about it and
then once we have that maybe we can talk
about
it okay so the first step in this
approach was to uh enumerate the regions
that we want to look at in order to
think about what visual concepts might
be covered um and so for this approach
we did uh Brute Force enumeration uh
where we just um we made a sort of
uh I have
565 two
I think it was like 224 by 224 box that
we just sort of scaled across the image
with a stride of 12 so that means like
skipping over 12 pixels kind of like
this right so I'm in NLP so this was
novel to Me Maybe This is really you
know everyone else knows about this but
this is the idea right you just kind of
go through you look at all these
different regions and each of these
regions you can then train to see if it
could possibly emit a word right and so
you do this over the entire image and
then you have this really dense uh
basically grid over over the image uh
that corresponds to tons of really rich
visual features um we sampled it at a
bunch of different scales so we had uh
we had boxes that you know could
incorporate other boxes um and from this
we had 190 boxes per images per image um
and then uh I'm going to say that we
call it a bag of boxes um and this bag
of boxes we can now use um in order to
try and uh output words so we used uh
conv ution neural network uh pre-trained
from imet and then fine-tuned on the
Coco data set um we ended up using
vggnet which uh is state-ofthe-art is
roughly state-ofthe-art now at least it
was state-of-the-art like four months
ago um it's moving very quickly so um so
we took that uh fine-tuned it on the
Coco data set um and then we said uh for
each word and for each box in each image
we can basically uh compute whether or
not there's possibly a word there right
so this is just a simple uh logistic
regression and I think this is probably
familiar to anyone who works on machine
learning um and the idea was that we
could use a noisy or multiple instance
learning in order to know what the
general visual concepts were in the
image so in previous Vision work one of
the difficulties uh one of the one of
the main things that they had to tackle
was the fact that you see tons and tons
of incorrect detections all over the
image so our thought about this was like
maybe we can just look at some things
we're pretty sure about um so for each
image we have this bag of boxes that I
just mentioned um and then we can look
at them in terms of positive and
negative instances for each word um and
then we can calculate the probability
that some image as a whole manifests
that visual concept um using this uh
noisy or uh multiple instance learning
method right um so uh we computed a
global Precision threshold and we uh
output all words above some threshold we
decided to look at Precision at human
recall uh which I don't think had been
looked at in Vision before but for every
word we can hold the the recall at the
human rate so whatever the human rate
for that word is and then we can look at
our Precision at that point and
threshold from there um so we do uh
pretty well using the multiple instance
learning approach and this is in
contrast to what most systems seem to be
doing now which is a full classification
approach where you take the whole image
and shove it through we broke the image
down into a bunch of bits um and we
found that we did quite well for both
Precision at human recall and for
average precision and here's some
examples um uh that we're using in
multiple instance learning here's a cat
here are a couple pictures of of a cat
uh there are two on the sink there
there's one on the toilet one of my
favorite things about giving Vision
talks is I can put up pictures of cats
which is really I can't do that in NLP
as much so that's pretty great um and
here's its detections for red um so you
can see that it's actually starting to
localize these things really reasonably
well um and we can leverage that to get
a sense of the common things to talk
about in the image right okay um so the
next up was language generation uh Which
is closest to my heart um with the idea
was uh we want to leverage a language
model um but we want to do it in a
clever way so the problem with using
vanilla language models is that they
tend to babble um the probability of a
word depends on previous words um if you
train a forr language model on a bunch
of Shakespeare you can get something
that sounds like Shakespeare
unfortunately it doesn't actually make a
lot of sense it makes sense locally but
not globally um so we thought about how
can we be clever about this in order to
have longdistance dependencies captured
to have Global Information be correct as
well as the local information um and uh
one word for this like local problem is
is we called the malovich problem where
you get into one state with one word and
then you end up saying the same thing
that you just said and you kind of
recurse from there um so we wanted to
get out of that sort of problem so our
thought on this was we can add basically
a Blackboard to keep track of all the
visual concepts that we want to generate
um and then encode that into our model
so instead of using a simple language
model um we decided to use a maximum
Entity framework where we can train
discriminatively on the visual concepts
as well as engrams so uh here we have
this global view uh afforded by the
multiple instance learning output we
remove a word when we generate it um and
then we keep track of it in terms of the
uh previous words that we've already
said um and we stop generating uh once
we've either hit end of sentence marker
or once we've covered all of our visual
concepts um and so from here we get from
the malovich problem to things that
actually start looking really reasonable
so uh a kitchen with wooden cabinets and
a
sink okay so uh to be very explicit
about this uh the maximum entropy
language model um just uses an ejected
function that's the log likelihood of
the captions conditioned on on the
detect objects um uh small note we used
a noise contrast of estimation uh so we
didn't have to calculate the exact
denominator denominator during training
um and uh we used nram features up to
four
GRS um here's our features right here uh
there's just a few but basically this is
keeping track of what the visual what
the score from the vision system is um
if if the thing we're producing is in
the Blackboard uh that where we're
keeping track of all the visual concepts
um and uh if it's if it's predicted by
uh the engram
statistics
okay right um for the generation process
we perform a left to right beam search
um truth be told a lot of these ideas
were originally outlined by um advate RN
Parky uh if you look at his work it's a
treasure Trove of cool ideas um so you
know we were we were sort of playing
with that um we maintained a stack of
partial hypotheses and this is pretty
familiar to people who work in machine
translation this is a sort of uh simple
decoding technique um from this we form
an M best list uh specifically the 500
captions that we think might be best
suited uh to the
image and then we start to rerank we
start to try and figure out which of
these are the
best so um you'll notice that we've only
used local information so far so the
detected words come from the box is
local in the image the caption is then
generated word by word but we haven't
captured any sense of global semantics
how does this whole sentence match to
the image if we take the image and the
sentence can we say that this is like
that right so the solution to this uh
was to project language and vision to a
common space um this is similar to what
Julia has done this is similar to what
uh a lot of people have done um but uh
we used a uh a technique that we've been
working on uh here at MSR uh it's based
off of uh what's called The Deep
semantic similarity model um because I
wanted to sell it to the cvpr
researchers I insisted we call it the
Deep multimodal similarity model um
unfortunately that means that now
there's something called the dssm and
the dmsm and they basically are
referring to the same thing so I I
apologize I didn't foresee that um but
basically the idea is that uh we want to
take a pair of neural networks one for
each input modality and train them
jointly um so we map images and
fragments to a common Vector
representation um with the intuition
being that if a picture corresponds to a
caption then the global vectors should
be trained to be close um and otherwise
they should be trained to be far away um
and we use uh cosine similarity uh to
measure the relevance between the two um
so uh the loss function minimized during
training uh repr uh represents the uh
well maybe this is too technical but
it's the negative log posterior
probability of the caption given the
corresponding image but the idea is
we're trying to say that this caption
and this image go together all
right um so we use the uh minimum error
rate training uh uh which is pretty
common in machine translation and it
helps us to rerank uh the set of all the
captions that we're thinking about um
and it just uses a linear combination of
features specifically these are the
features um the length of the sequence
um
these are actually quite standard in
machine translation so we just sort of
borrowed it from there um as well as
some indicator features for whether or
not uh n attributes were included and we
found that in general including uh uh
four visual concepts gave us a full um
fluent sounding uh description of an
image okay um our results um these are a
lot of numbers to look at uh we talked
about this a bit in the in the opening
session but I mean we really just
agonized over the fact that although we
had all these metrics uh we looked at
perplexity we looked at Blue we looked
at meteor um if you actually looked at
the captions and how the data was
changing how the output was changing as
we we messed with different parameters
we didn't feel it was actually um
accurately capturing the changes that we
were getting and in fact we found that
human written captions got a blue score
of 19.3 our best system is getting a
blue score of
25.7 so like okay clearly something's
wrong here we're superhuman according to
automatic metrics um so we took a look
at uh human evaluation as well where we
had uh the annotators decide whether one
image uh with a corresponding caption
was better described with caption a or
caption B randomized um and we found
that uh our system was chosen as being
uh the same as or better than a human
description in 34% of the cases um just
for uh everyone's knowledge when you pit
a human against another human you get
around 70% so we still have a gap to
make up there it's not 100% though um
and we got a lot of help uh with the the
Deep multimodal similarity
model okay so putting it together the
overall procedure was to create create
the data set which uh which created the
we gave rise to the Microsoft Coco data
set and then suddenly everybody
everywhere was also using it and doing
the same sort of thing so that was like
really exciting and accelerating um we
then uh did the image analysis language
model and a
ranker um we then uh were actually also
uh able to test on a heldout uh test Set
uh that was provided by the organizers
at uh at cvpr part of this Coco cvpr um
challenge captioning
challenge
um um I'm not going to get too much into
the metrics I think it's a little bit
more fun to actually look at the
examples of what's going on um so so
briefly uh this is the kind of thing
that uh the turkers uh were taking a
look at when they're making their
decisions uh so sorry they didn't see
the underlying uh information but they
saw the output of this I'm showing you
what our system was actually thinking so
um we get an image of a baseball player
we uh use multiple instance learning and
we eventually say we think there's some
baseball in here so we generate a
baseball player here's what player looks
like you can see activations all around
the uh pose Associated to being a player
a baseball player um throwing so here
it's focusing in on the leg muscle as as
a as the guy is getting ready to throw
right
uh and ball here it's localized directly
on the ball and that's without direct uh
any sort of direct annotation from us um
so we eventually end up outputting
something like a baseball player
throwing a
ball um a nice property of this is the
interpretability of it so this is what
we see when we see man uh we we tend to
focus on the sort of facial features
here the presence of a beard is a strong
indicator a man sitting in a couch maybe
should have said on a couch uh with a
dog right okay so how did we do it
turned out that there were a ton uh of
different competing systems all doing
the same thing with the same data at the
same time there were ended up being a
total of 15 different systems uh that
ended up competing on the same heldout
test data set um we submitted a couple
but this was uh you know Berkeley
Stanford Google B Toronto uh UCLA
Montreal just you know tons of people um
and so it was fun to take a look at the
similarities and differences between all
the approaches um what you notice here
though is human is way near the bottom
right so we're all doing great given our
objective functions humans just suck so
um maybe we're superhuman um
unfortunately uh we're not superhuman
but we're getting close so in the cvpr
challenge they went a little bit further
and they put this out to humans and said
what do you think about these um we
ended up tying in first place uh where
our system had the highest percentage of
captions that pass the touring test so
thought to be written by a human um and
the percentage of captions that are most
similar to human
description uh we also submitted a
second system where we took a gated
recurr recurrent neural network and did
some Force decoding um that got a second
place uh but it also got the highest
score on the average correctness of the
captions okay so just a quick sum
summary um we've developed a
state-of-the-art image captioning system
and explored several methods in order to
look at all the different varied nuances
uh at the interface of vision and
language um but there are so many more
things to do um as as Julia mentioned
and I'm sure Richard will mention as
well um we want language to become more
Rich more Nuance we want to begin
incorporating background information and
and common sense so we know when things
are super remarkable and when things are
probably not actually happening um and
we want to be able to start speaking and
learning in real time bootstrapping from
there okay and our relevant papers on
this are at cvpr 2015 and ACL 2015 okay
thanks any
questions
so this is not a criticism but I thought
both of the captions for the tennis
player were kind of lousy and so when I
saw well I should show you our and best
list because some of them are awesome so
I wonder if has there been any work done
to take the kind of captions that you
get from multiple humans and put them up
and lie to the evaluators and just say
which of these is a Compu and see if
people like them oh we did that what yes
okay so I did talk about this so so one
we justed human versus human um and and
that got to one human was voted to be
70% equal to or better than the other
human um we also did a nearest neighbors
approach which has been sort of standard
uh baselines in a lot of vision to
language work and we found that a
nearest neighbor approach is actually
quite good at this um we still beat it
handily um but not all systems that are
being developed that are the you know
end to end CNN to RNN kind of thing do
beat the nearest neighbor approach oh
and this is really exciting read our ACL
paper the lstm approach actually seems
to be mimicking the nearest neighbor
approach so it seems to actually just be
learning a nearest neighbor function so
it's kind of
fun one more question uh in the front
here right
there thanks um once the system is
trained can you give some sense of how
much CPU time it takes to classify or
create the caption for one image so uh
you know how real time is it basically
once it's done yeah um so I haven't
timed it as clearly as I should we did
time it going back through a web server
like displaying and D that actually took
a full minute uh just I mean I can just
give you a you know a vague estimate of
around 20 seconds I could it's not that
fast sure and is that like a single CPU
many CPUs like what would that be uh
yeah I think it's like a single CPU it's
I mean we haven't tried to we actually
haven't tried to set this up for Speed
yet so it's not it's not very good to
look at this for benchmarking speed
because there's probably a lot of things
we can do we were just trying to see
what it did sure
thanks who was first you guys
know
so I was thinking a little bit about
Julia's example about the woman pushing
the child and the other child watching
and just wondering about sort of
asymmetric binary relations like left of
right of pushing being pushed does that
come out of what you're doing how does
that
happen um yeah so we're uh there's a lot
of really interesting work we're doing
on this um I don't know how much I
should say um uh some of it does come
out um so one really exciting thing that
I found
uh that maybe people in the vision
Community disagree with was that the
system started to be subitizing so for
numbers 2 3 and four it's just
recognizing that like an entity and
that's sort of
unexpected um for the sort of asymmetric
relations uh I think that's probably one
of our weaknesses that's definitely a
place where where we can improve we are
good at looking at a couple things at
once and saying something about it so in
the case of counting right we're looking
at two things at once and we're able to
say two uh but in terms of being able to
say the specific relation like this guy
is left of that guy we're still working
on
it one more question I had a question uh
good talk um I had some application I
mean like practical question uh I don't
know if you evaluate the impact of the
global term you have like this local
term and the global term and if you know
what is the impact of adding all this
Global Information about the images yeah
uh so there's a few places I think
you're probably talking specifically
about the dmsm um and those those
numbers are in the cvpr paper we get uh
we get like a two or three blueo boost
uh with the dmsm so okay and also in
terms of the size of the data sets for
example if you double the size of the
Coco dat we tried I mean we didn't
double it we tried training on train and
Val and then uh just testing on like a
couple sentences and then we actually
put those up onto the official server
for the heldout test set and we did not
see a significant Improvement um so it
might be the case that well there's
there's a lot of reasons but but yeah um
adding another uh 40,000 uh captions
didn't
help all right I think we'll stop there
let's thank Meg
again
all right so next up and our last
speaker is Rich ZL he is a professor at
the University of Toronto and in his own
words he has interest in inference and
learning in biological and artificial
systems uh in my words I really look at
rich as being uh one of the people at
the Forefront of the language and vision
uh Trend right now he's done some really
cool stuff on attention modeling with
language and vision and he's also done
some uh from this morning maybe slightly
controversial work or named the work
called thought vectors which maybe he'll
be talking about today all right thanks
Larry okay so uh really happy to be part
of this uh uh session today and and uh
two speakers before me did a great job
both um Julia and and Meg talking about
image captioning uh I'm going to talk
about image captioning but but focus
more on machine learning issues all
right so uh and so I want to start I
know many of you are familiar with it
especially was talked about in the first
session this morning with uh the big
success of so-called deep networks these
big neural networks that are trained on
lots of data uh and to do things that
are typically classification problems
where the idea is that for every input
you have one particular Target and the
aim is to classify that Target correctly
so for an image you might want to say
what's the dominant object in this image
um and everybody knows I think that the
these have done remarkably well well on
things like speech recognition and
object recognition um and the main aim
in such systems is to generalize beyond
the training set you want to be able to
take images that may be slightly
different but similar to training images
and classify those correctly and so the
success uh means that you're able to
generalize and and so some recent
Studies have shown that these systems
despite their uh notable successes
actually don't generalize very well
they're in fact quite brittle so
somebody did a study where what they did
was they took the images that are shown
here on the uh on the left uh and those
were all classified correctly and then
what they did is they added a little bit
uh to every pixel so that's shown by a
heat map in the middle and they produced
the images that are shown on the right
and in this case it turns out that the
same network that did really well in the
images on the left classified all the
images on the right as an
ostrich okay so the generalization was
not so good here right um so that's a an
important aim from the machine learning
world is to come up with high quality
generic representations meaning that
they're useful in lots of different
tasks and so what I'm going to talk
about today are a few efforts a few
different uh things that I've done with
my group mostly with my students and
also with some other colleagues aimed at
this at this idea of coming up with
generic representations and most of it
concerns coming up with new objectives
so new objectives we talked about a
little bit this morning as well where
it's not about these kind of supervised
standard classification kind of
objectives but instead more unsupervised
based on things like image and text
statistics and co-occurrences
so the first objective along these lines
is one that has to do with context
prediction where the idea is you get an
input that comes as a set of things
let's say a pair and the aim is to take
one item of the pair and predict the
other right and uh and the standard
setup for these kinds of things as
actually mentioned in a couple of the
talks before is that you have a kind of
end code coder that's going to map from
the first input of the pair to some
vector and then take that vector and
decode it to come up with the second
input of the pair all right so that's
the kind of basic setup you want to have
in mind for most of the things I'm going
to be talking about today and this has
been used very successfully for example
there's a system where you feed it tons
of sentences and sentences that can come
from things like books or Wikipedia
articles or lots of things and the aim
of the network is to take a word and map
a word to a vector and then from that
vector be able to predict both the word
that comes before and after it and the
word that be it comes you know two words
after it and and uh two words before it
and that's a so-called skip gram model
and that becomes a very useful
representation for words right so what
we've done recently is abstracted this
idea to whole sentences so not dealing
with words but whole sentences so we
take this encode or decod or model you
feed it as a sentence and the aim of it
is to predict the sentence that comes
before it in the sentence that comes
after it so here you can have a sentence
that says I could see the cat on the
steps and it has to predict the sentence
before it which was I got back home and
the afterwards was uh this was strange
okay so that's our uh our system that
we've developed and we call the skip
thought vectors and this was in fact the
one that was spoken of uh dismissively
this morning um but we're actually
really happy with how it's uh it's
working let me tell you a little bit
more about it um the a of it is well we
train it up on 74 million sentences and
it takes about a week um to do this kind
of prediction where we're predicting the
sentence before it and the sentence
after it uh and then what we do is we
want to show that this is actually a
very useful kind of generic
representation that's useful in all
kinds of natural language processing
tasks so we took five different NLP
tasks things like semantic relatedness
and paraphrase detection and we showed
that just building a simple linear
classifier on top of these
representations did very well on these
tasks it didn't beat the
state-of-the-art but it was competitive
with them and all the state-of-the-art
methods in these cases used very kind of
customized hand tune features the idea
is we have a generic representation
that's quite powerful and useful across
different tasks right so that's one
example of this kind of idea of
predicting context here you're
predicting one sentence from the other
another one is in the captioning work so
we want to be able to predict captions
from an image like on the left you want
to predict the castle and the reflecting
water from that image or you can predict
an image from a caption like the ship
sailing on the ocean uh that image from
that caption and so this is something
that Julia spoke about and actually
meged it as well I won't spend much time
on it the same idea we want to map to
some sort of space a joint space such
that things that are nearby in that
space are related so it's a kind of
semantic related space and we train it
up using a kind of uh ranking objective
where captions that aren't paired up
with the image are actually far away
okay so that's the objective that
showing below and then what we do it to
decode this so This Is the End coding we
map it to this space and the decoding is
a word by word generative decoding so
there was a question about that earlier
so we're actually generating words one
at a time using something called a
neural language model that generates a
word and then generates the following
word based on the words that have been
generated so far as well as this uh
semantic representation so that's the
way we have been doing image captioning
and we gotten pretty good results on on
that approach Okay so that's one kind of
objective this uh context
prediction a second objective is that we
want to take this idea of generating
things seriously we want to actually
look at the quality of what's being
generated and so in this case for
example we want to be able to generate
images that look like real images right
um and again we want to be able to
generalize beyond the training set so we
don't want to fall into the same trap I
was talking about that the
classification methods have where you
can kind of memorize the training set
and do a really good job of generating
realistic images but all you're doing is
reproducing the training examples so the
question is how can you formulate an
objective that allows you to generalize
in this
case so here there's some uh work recent
work that's become quite popular
something called an adversarial approach
so you want to have an adversary out
there and the idea is that you're going
to build a system that's going to
generate a bunch of images and you're
going to put the adversary out and it's
the adversary has to tell which image
was generated by the model which one was
generated which one is real which one
was generated by Nature all right
and uh so this has been used to to good
effect recently but there's a an
optimization issue that's a problem with
these kinds of methods and and the real
the problem is that the adversary is
kind of adapting as your model is coming
up with a new way of Genera images and
then your image U model creation is
going to adapt as the adversary adapts
so it's a bit of a circular thing it's
like a dog chasing its own tail and this
type of thing leads to a hard
minimization problem and so so they get
a lot of local Minima in this
optimization so we developed a different
approach uh with a couple of my students
where the idea
was it's uh Illustrated here on the left
you want to think of you have some again
that that H is some sort of vector space
and we're going to draw vectors randomly
from some uniform prior distribution in
that space and then just R run through a
standard feedforward neural network
deterministic feed Network and produce
an image as the output so you might
produce the things shown on on the left
side that are look somewhat like uh
handwritten digits and then what we want
to do is train those up so that they
look like the data so they actually look
like real
data and the novel idea here is that we
don't want to do this on an image by
image example instead we want to get the
statistics right we want to say overall
the statistics of our samples should
look like the statistics of the true
data okay not that each image should
match a given image and that's what's
going to enable us to do some
generalization and the way we accomplish
it is using this what we call the MMD or
the maximum mean discrepancy measure
this is something that comes from the
statistics Community uh and I won't go
into the details on it but the basic
idea is that you have think of you have
two sets of samples one comes from in
our case one comes from the uh actual
training set and one comes from the
model and we want this is a distance
measure that says how close are they or
what's the another way of saying is
what's the probability that they were
actually drawn from the same probability
distribution so if they're drawn from
the same distribution then the these two
samples should be indistinguishable
right so our idea was to use this as an
objective for training so we want to
minimize this metric so it looks like
the two samples were drawn from the same
distribution and that has a couple good
properties uh first thing is that it's
easy to compute so that you know it's a
big equation but it's actually very
straightforward to compute and the
second thing is it has exact what we
want which is that if we can force this
measure to zero that means that the two
distributions are the same and you can't
tell them apart and that means that more
technically that they match in all of
their moments the distributions match so
the first order moments the means match
the second order the variance matches
and all the higher order moments as well
so if you can force it to zero then
you'll say that the samples look exactly
like the data so it's a very good
measure to optimize for our
task
okay so this is the version of our model
that works the best where again we have
this encoder and decoder part of it and
we have the you generation from this you
know latent variable H this Vector space
down to the images and we try to make
that look like the
data and we again try to get the
statistics of the samples to get S be
similar to the statistics of the data as
measured by this MMD
criteria and here's a few quantitative
results uh so we compare what we call
our gmmn which is generative moment
matching networks with an encoder that's
the bottom one that's our best version
of the system against a bunch of other
uh models and what we're comparing here
is based on an estimate of the log
likelihood of some heldout data on two
different data sets one is the
handwritten data set the mnus set and
the other one is a bunch of images from
of faces uh and you can see that we do
better than the other networks other
systems incl including the adversarial
networks I was talking about
before so this is some quantitative
results I think it's always more fun to
look at qualitative results uh and so
here's some pictures uh so at the top
you see these are some of the samples
that are drawn from our system that was
trained on the faces and you can see
that they look somewhat like you know
these are just independent draws by
taking the random Vector running it
through the network and producing an
image and then what we did is we wanted
to explicitly ask about generalization
and so one way to do that is to say well
we can take a generated image and say
well let's try to find the closest image
in the training set and compare them and
what you can so this is what's shown on
the bottom the top row are the ones that
we generated the bottom row are their uh
corresponding nearest neighbor and you
can see that some of them are quite
similar but they're different so they
get the sense that we're making some
progress on this uh aim of trying to
generalize from the training
set here's another view of what's
happening so another think fun thing you
can do is so again like said you you
generate an image by taking some random
Vector in this uh H in this uh Vector
space at the top of the network that
you're going to run through so we can
take two different vectors and draw a
line between them and for every one of
those for every one of each of ones at
the end and some evenly spaced points in
between we can generate an image and
that's what's shown here so if you see
the one in red in the corner that's one
randomly chosen point in the image that
corresponds to it and then two rows
below it there's another one that's
highlighted in Red so that's the other
chosen point and then along the way we
can generate images that go along that
those points in this Vector space and
you can see you get some interesting
Behavior so from the second one down you
can see it starts at something that
looks a bit like a two and then it kind
of morphs into maybe an eight and then a
three and then it becomes like a zero
okay so it's seems like we've captured
something
here uh that's in the digit data set so
we do the same thing on the faces same
same idea choose a random point in the
space generate an image choose another
random point and then generate images
all the way along for I think like the
25 points in between and those are the
kind of faces you get okay so it does
some sort of interpolation it's
interesting simply it's captured some of
the variations what was talking about
that naturally underly the data set so
in this case there's things like
lighting and gender and you know
mustaches um various things that are
variations in the the uh in the image
space okay so here they we think we're
getting at capturing the kind of
underlying manifold uh in which in the
image
space
okay so the third objective the last one
I want to talk about is one that I think
is it's something we've just just
started working on very recently and in
this case we want to go beyond this we
want to extend not just generate let's
say one image but generate a set of
related images or a set of related
sentences and here it's not really about
necessarily saying that we want to have
a powerful representation I think that
this is just an interesting case in and
of itself the question is there's a lot
of things in AI that are basically
inherently ambiguous questions that we
want to be able to tackle so I think
this is a fundamental AI question so an
example is image segmentation all right
so here you have an image shown on the
left and you have two different
segmentations the one on the uh the one
in the middle you see they have a
segmentation where the top of the image
is fairly well the regions are fairly
well segmented but the person's kind of
ignored what's happening in the back in
the foreground and the and the one on
the right a different person the
different segmentor annotator has
instead paid a lot of attention to
what's going on in the foreground and
hasn't done much in terms of the
background and both of these are
perfectly valid so I think of this as
you know the the task of segmentation
has some ambiguity and think of it as a
kind of one the many problem you have
one image and many valid
segmentations similarly when you
generate captions it's the same thing
you have this and uh you this was
mentioned Julia mentioned this earlier
you have a an image shown on the left
and you can generate two things like at
least two things a car on a beach with a
boat in the background or two hilly
islands in the water again both of these
are
valid so we can think of this as a
problem of diversity and people in this
audience know have worked on diversity
as a as a interesting question and of
itself and one thing that we can get at
here is what's the appropriate level of
diversity in these kinds of one one the
many mappings what are the kinds of
things we want the captions to be
diverse in what ways and the nice thing
is that we have data available to help
us answer this so for instance the MS
Coco data set that was talked about
earlier that's been a great uh resource
for the community there you have tons of
images each of them has at least five
captions so that gives you some
diversity per image and in fact there's
a subset of them that has 50 captions
per image so that's a lot of potential
you know a lot of one to many or many
being 50 in that case so that's a good
very good learning set for this one to
many
problems and the our approach to this is
to take what I was describing Before Our
Moment matching Network that goes from
some Vector space down to the uh output
space in this case the output space
could be a caption not an image but now
we're going to condition on an input
where the input will be a particular
image all right and we've also
reformulated our objective so the aim is
no longer to match the statistics of all
of the images to all of or all of the
captions to all the C that we generate
to all the captions in the data set
instead it's very input dependent or
image specific in this case we want to
take let's say the five captions that
exist for that image and look at the
statistics of those five captions and
match that with the five captions or set
of captions that we're going to generate
from our system okay so that's the aim
is to do it on an image by image
basis so this is some work some recent
work with uh some of my students and I
won the details are takes like 6,000
training images and one of the flicker
data sets Julia mentioned each one of
them has five captions and so we want to
get those the statistic of those five
captions our system is going to generate
a bunch of captions and get those to
match right and I could show you a few
results here the bottom row is looking
at the blue score which is a mention
that a few people uh sorry a measure
that a few people have mentioned and
what you can see without looking at so
our method is shown in blue and the
green method is a nearest neighbor
method and so so this illustrates
something that was also said which is
nearest neighbor methods do great on on
image captioning so in some sense we
aren't doing as well on Blue Square but
if you look in a different space like
the vector space of semantic relatedness
which is actually using our skip thought
vectors that I talked about earlier our
our system as shown in blue above is
actually beating all the other methods
handily and I think that's a better
measure for blue score has a lot of
flaws I think our skip thw Vector is a
better way of saying how related
sentences
are and now just for fun to actually see
some examples so this isn't you won't be
super impressed with our results here uh
but they're kind of so here's an example
I chose that are more just fun rather
than the best results so I don't know if
you can see it there's a dog or a weird
looking dog with a bunch of tennis balls
and you can see some of our captions
there uh and you can see that there's
the captions are plausible and actually
capture some
diversity uh here's another example one
of my favorite ones uh just cuz it's a
strange image but also you can look at
some of our captions um and in in fact
here I think we capture something
interesting right so part of the caption
is focusing on you can see it says it
has a colorful costume so our captions
are the one at the top says a blonde
woman in a colorful costume it's not
quite right but it's somewhat plausible
and then one underneath the female
performer with a rainbow wig instead of
looking at the costume it's focusing on
the uh the hair of the person which
plausibly could be a wig um and here's
another case of basketball player with a
few of the captions that we generate
right
so the so to wrap up I want to uh go
back to my claim a real strong
representation is one that can not only
do recognition for objects and words but
can model the inputs in their contexts
and there I've talked about a few
objectives that get at that trying to
predict context sentences from sentences
and captions from sentences and vice
versa and also go further be able to
generate distributions of images or in
the last case generate distributions of
sentences that may be specific to an
image and the last thing I want to talk
about a little bit of where we're going
with this so how do we actually leverage
these generative models and so one thing
is to gain insight into the Model
Behavior and Meg mentioned this so one
thing that we've done is look at an
attention based system so the idea in
the attention based system is now when
you're going to generate captions you
aren't going to generate a caption based
on the whole image instead what you're
going to do is look at specific regions
in the image and every time that the
system finds a region in the image it's
going to generate a word for that region
then it's going to move to another
region generate another word okay so we
have this attention based system and if
you follow along the bottom row you have
the image shown on the left and you can
see that it kind of looks down and it
says uh to the left it says bird down
below flying over a body of water right
so it's attending to different parts of
the image and generating words specific
to those parts of the image so that's
something that we've run and actually so
in the competition that was just
mentioned at the end of Meg's talk uh
this is done with some colleagues in
Toronto and also in Montreal and this
system didn't place in the top five it
was like I think sixth or seventh maybe
on the uh some of the metrics like the
blue and cider and these other metrics
but when we came to the human evaluators
actually our system did quite well in
fact I think it was the only one overall
that was in the top four that wasn't one
of the industry-based uh things so that
was our little we were happy about
that um some other things we want to do
is try to leverage these generative
models see if we can actually improve
classification tasks and finally we're
turning our attention to things like
video and trying to do the same types of
things now on video that's it
thanks this great I have two question
okay uh both in terms of some of the
issues discussed in um in the morning's
panel discussion yeah the first one is
that um the way you train your moment
met Network it stri to me that you
actually do use the supervision right
you match with the statistics and use
that to you know to do the training so
that to me is yeah more like right so
there's an interesting semantics to this
of what does supervision mean so
Supervision in that case though we
aren't actually require so typically
think of supervision is some human has
to come into the loop and add some
labels okay right so labeling being like
the fact that this image contains you
know a hippopotamus or something dist
supervision so not the real question is
that uh I I remember you were one of the
authors for uh for this paper uh sleep
uh a w sleep algorithm many years ago
that's true so I just and that was
actually purely General U un learning
modeling the data distribution so do you
compare this so this is still so this is
still all we have is the data here the
difference like I say in some ways the
difference is you have an image and in
one case you're trying to reconstruct
that particular image so that's your
standard kind of generative model
instead what we're doing is saying
forget about the single image you aren't
actually trying to reconstruct the image
instead you're measuring statistics on
the entire data set of images and trying
to match that okay so okay so it's no
there's no additional supervision signal
it's just kind of recasting the
objective okay so you believe that this
way of training based upon uh moment
matching is better
than deep uh sleep and okay have you
compare there or is just speculation uh
so so far the Wake sleep algorithms I
think there are some very good methods
recently for doing that uh or recent
versions of the Wake sleep methods
recasting of them that work quite well
things like called variational
autoencoders is one name you know if
you're familiar with that uh those do
quite well uh and but I think that the
they haven't shown the ability to do
quite the same kind of manifold
representations that we are they're able
to do things uh in other spaces but I
think that you know so the the two of
them have different strengths I would
say Okay okay so the second question I'm
sorry the second question is that um so
have you ever tried to use your skip
thought Vector as the feature extractor
to fit into another you know classifier
uh so that you know you can do some
classific task if you believe that's
what we were doing in the NLP task I was
talking about we were using we were
taking sentences and we were using these
as mapping them to this Vector space and
then those vectors were the input to
some simp linear classifier for one of
these you know one of these five
different tasks I talked about like
semantic relatedness or different things
that's exactly what we were doing in
that Cas are you able to beat the end to
end learning without using yeah so so
again it's like it's not completely it
doesn't beat the state-ofthe-art but
it's competitive okay great thank you
very
much another
question I'm just trying to get an idea
for scale here you said early on that
one of these uh the training time for
one of these problems for this 74
million sentences or whatever was was a
week Y what kind of process was that
what kind of system was it on was that
parallelized and not on a big enough
system is it on a Serial computer what
did you do yeah so that wasn't highly
optimized or it runs on gpus but it's
not running uh we could definitely
optimize that and run it much faster and
farm it o over many more processors it
hasn't been optimized for that at all
and uh in fact it's gotten better now
we're we're over like a over a couple
hundred
million sentences and uh can train it in
a couple weeks but I'm clearly that can
that can improve we haven't to spent
effort on that right
now any other
questions no okay let's thank uh Rich
again and that uh concludes the
session